Presentation. And we will now move on to the budget workshop for Solid
Waste Management.
Okay, thank you.
Good afternoon, everyone. Mark Wolffolk, Solid Waste Department.
Six months in. I just wanted to put that cat out there so you
all go easy on me today, all right?
Also want to thank our staff for getting me to this point.
I just mentioned, been here six months, but everybody's been working
together. The Synergy has been great, but I just want to
go ahead and throw another caveat out there on this presentation today.
You're dealing with two rookies, right? So I'm here.
I'm also flanked by our assistant director. How many months
has it been? Two months. Two months?
Yeah. Assistant director, wealthy, white. So congratulations
to her. She's still hanging.
Okay, so we'll go ahead and just get into the budget
presentation. Apologize. I kind of
broke the traditional format that you all follow, but I do want to concentrate
on the budget portion. So if we could go to the next slide.
I just wanted to give you all an overview of our executive leadership team here.
I think the key takeaway from this slide is that we have about
427 positions in the department.
And the other key takeaway from
this slide is and I mentioned earlier how the team has been working with Synergy.
Our deputy director, Anthony Booy, that's here today. I like to recognize him.
This will be his last budget presentation. Go around with us. After 42
plus years, he's getting ready to retire. So definitely like to recognize
Mr. Anthony Booy for his contribution.
So we've got some big shoes to fill there.
So next slide, please. The demographic
data. Just wanted to give you just a little quick overview of that. Of course,
77% of that department is African American,
followed by Hispanic,
Latino, and then white and Asian. But to me,
the biggest takeaway of this is the diversity, gender diversity that we have
in the department and the amount of women that we have that
are doing the jobs today in solid waste management.
So I just really wanted to focus on that. That 29% to 30%
really caught my eye when I arrived to the city. And I think there's
just more good works to come. Next slide.
Just why do we have to have solid waste department? For these
three reasons. Right here you have the Solid Waste Disposal Act of 1965,
as well as the Texas Health and Safety Code, and of course, the city code
and ordinances. And of course, without effective solid waste management,
our neighborhoods would be overrun by all types of
vermin and really have deplorable conditions in the neighborhood.
Next slide. You're all familiar
with the forward facing departments that we have or forward facing
business units that we have. So I won't spend much time there, except for on
the last yellow highlighted area there.
In addition to all of the services that we provide on a weekly,
monthly or bimonthly basis. We also focus
hard on those other support services such as homeless
encampment abatement program, the litter abatement program, as well
as many of the council district service funds and keeping
those programs going as well. Next slide.
Okay, just a functional review of our organizational chart.
You'll see where basically we have three different
sections in the department. It's either going to be north operations,
south Operations, or Administration. And whatever
doesn't fall in there will also fall under
our maintenance category. But as you can see, the estimated
total for this FY 23 year will be about $95.6 million.
All right, next slide, please. At this point, I'd like to
turn this point of the presentation over to our CFO, Ms. Wealthy White.
Thank you, Director. The solid waste department revenues
are generated through two funds the general fund and
the recycling revenue fund. The General Fund revenues
includes fees from our dumpster permits,
our extra capacity container program, our nonresidential
garbage and our container lease fee and some
other small accounts. The Recycling Revenue
Fund is generated from the sale of recyclable materials
like glass, scrap metal,
batteries, electronics which are sold by the City.
Also included in this fund are fees from our
tire recycling and our business recycling programs.
On this slide, we see a projected 3%
increase in General Fund revenues due to the annual
CPI and prior year revenue activity
to be realized in fiscal year 2023.
There is no projected increase in the Recycling
Revenue Fund, and with these revenue funds, we have
a total budget revenue budget of $14.8 million.
Next slide, please. Our expenditures
by funds are our department,
our collection programs and other service delivery
components. Includes our garbage collection, tree waste,
heavy trash depositories,
curbside recycling, drive through recycling
facilities, sponsorships. All these areas
are supported by the General Fund. And the fiscal
year 2023 proposed budget is $95.6
million, which represents a 1% increase
from the current fiscal year.
The Recycling Revenue Fund proposed expenditure
supports the City's recycling programs, related services
and recycling education. The proposed budget
for fiscal year 2023 is $4.1 million
and it represents a 5% increase from
fiscal year 2022. Next slide,
please.
Looking at go ahead.
Yeah, they're ahead. You can go ahead and explain if you can back up one
slide to the pie chart. Thank you. The projected budget
by fund for fiscal year 2023 in the General Fund
budget, personnel represents 41% of the total
budget. nonpersonal accounts for 59%
of the proposed budget, and within that 59% services
are 23%. And restricted accounts,
supplies, non, capital transfer and debt make
up the balance of 36%. In the
Recycling Revenue Fund, the percentage for personnel
is ten point 57 and nonpersonal is
89%. The next slide shows
the net change in the General Fund. Next slide,
please. Thank you.
At the start of fiscal year 2022,
the Solid Waste Management Department began with a budget of $89
million and with adjustments throughout the
year, it increased the budget to 95,
601, 576. Looking forward
to the fiscal year 2023 General Fund budget.
Additional adjustments were made to include contractual and
mandated adjustments resulting in a proposed budget
of $95,610,939,
which is again a net change of
approximately 1% from the current year's
budget. Next slide.
All right. Thank you, Ms. White. Now with this FY
23 proposed budget, we do expect some
impacts and a lot of those impacts are going to come just
by growth and demand, increasing growth in demand throughout
the city. We also expect some of those impacts
to be attributed to the vacancy rates that we currently have that we're working on
driving down overtime, as well as temporary
services that we'll use to mitigate some of the shortfalls that we incur
throughout the year. Operational program
subsidies will be another area that we think will also impact. And that's
just from observation of being here a little more than six months.
Meaning that we may at times have some a need to
supplement our services by calling in help from some of our
private counterparts in the industry that will be in the areas of heavy
trash collection which we're about to embark upon right now,
as well as curbside recycling. And then again,
we have challenges with addressing some of the neighborhood density projects that
are going on and some of the inflationary contracts
that we're seeing or inflationary impact to contracts that we're seeing today.
Next slide.
Okay, again, FY 22 accomplishments.
There have been several that have been going on prior to my arrival and
then since my arrival, they've continued to keep
the momentum going. I think the biggest takeaway throughout the
year has been the fact that the city has gotten aggressive and they recognize
the fact that we've had a shortage in some of our key
or critical positions, that being the driving positions. And the
$3,000 sign in bonus was great for a while,
but now we're recognizing the fact that everybody else
has gotten hip to the game. So we've got to continuously
think of something new and innovative to recruit and attract more
talent. So Mayor Turner actually, and as well as some of the council
members here, have been instrumental in kind of helping us develop CDL
training programs that we're currently working on right now. And then
we're also actively, still actively recruiting licensed
CDL drivers, but we've also got a pay increase on
the way for them as well. So hopefully that will continue to attract more
qualified talent in this area. Next slide.
Some of the FY 23 goals. Again I think the biggest goal that we have
that you'll hear me constantly say is we want to reduce
our dependency on the general fund. Meaning that we want to become
a more sustainable department in the way that we, we manage our department,
the way that we manage our resources and again become more solvent
in that process. We want to diversify the revenue streams
I know there's a lot of talk about the city of Houston not having
a residential rate and then that is the case too.
We would love to continue working on that and there's some other opportunities as
well to diversify the revenue streams as
well as it involves working
in the commercial sector or offering our services to some of the
commercial programs that may be out there throughout the city.
We also plan to reduce our vacancy rate. We're currently hovering around
17% right now, department wide, maybe about 15%
for our critical vacancies. Again, working with Mayor Turner,
adjusting the starting salary that should be taking place within the
next couple of days. We noticed that we think we'll be a little
bit more competitive with our counterparts in the private industry
and get our starting rate up closer to $22, $23 an hour.
And then we really want to work on standardizing our routes too.
And a lot of this has to do with the growth. And that's a good
thing. The growth that the city of Houston has incurred over the last decade.
And it's time for the solid waste department to catch up with that growth right
now so that we can continue our quest and accomplish our goals
as far as delivering on time services concerned. Next slide.
It's just a little graph and some studies that we've been doing again with the
long cities or the department's long range plan that's been out there.
Just a couple of facts over the last ten years. I believe
we see now the population of the city of Houston being about 6.6 million.
To us, that represents about 20,000 additional households
that we're still servicing with the same level of
organizational support that we had ten years ago.
And again about a 300 or 225 ton
increase on a daily basis that we're still responsible for collecting.
So we definitely feel the strain. Now the bottom, the other arrows may seem
a little bit confusing because we have it pointing down, but it says 2%
increase. The reason I did that is because again,
the city has grown exponentially in those ten years and the department has not
kept up with that growth and that's why we're experiencing
such challenges with service delays, probably a less than
a 1% increase and no increase in the size of the fleet.
You'll hear me constantly say we got to invest in our greatest assets,
employees and equipment. Without those two,
we can't deliver that service. Next slide. I'm sorry, can you hold
that slide for a second? The top of the
chart, the line graph, just kind of illustrates that relationship
that you have. Most cities our
size has when it comes down to full time employees, to number of
households served. And you'll see the blue
line, which represents our FTEs,
normally should be above that orange line.
As far as households serve, you want to keep that relationship.
Houston is at the end. You see there's a big disparity there when
it comes down to our counterparts.
Next slide. And that
concludes our presentation. Happy to answer any questions that anyone may
have. Thank you, Director. First question comes from Council member Abby Cayman.
Thanks, Chair. First Director.
Thank you. And please relay our appreciation to
everyone in the department, especially our drivers that are out in the field.
Are they still working six days a week right now?
Yes, we're still at six days a week, hopefully not much longer.
Yeah, and I know I've seen some drivers out there. We all
work late, but not as late as they do. We're not up as early as
they are. So please relay my gratitude to them really
quickly. I wanted to check in because we talked about
the increase in multifamily and looking at
additional needs towards the future.
I had passed, with the support of council last fiscal year,
a budget amendment that was going to direct the department by
the end of fiscal year 22 to start the stakeholder
engagement process. So we can be looking at mandatory
multifamily recycling, whether the city takes on that burden or not,
just requires private, but where are
we in that process and has that begun yet? Yes,
and that's a good question. I'm happy to report that process is going,
it is ongoing. I believe the team started that
prior to my arrival and since then, now we are
to the point where we are meeting biweekly and when
I say we, I'm talking about members of the Apartment Association
and other industrial and
commercial businesses throughout town that represents those areas.
Perfect, because as we talk about future needs, and I know many of us around
the Horseshoe bring this up as to you, the life cycle
of our landfills and if we do not start curbing waste now,
we're going to be in big trouble. So I thank you for that
update. And in terms of the profitability of
recycling materials right now, are we seeing an improvement in that?
Yes, there's been a slight improvement in there. I think our CFO can attest
to that as well. In fact, I don't believe we
have to pay our processor now. Is that correct? Yeah. So the
way our contract is set up is that when the materials, the blended value
of the materials reaches a certain threshold that the city
doesn't have to pay. Right. And just one follow up on that and then I'll
go back in the queue. There was an
effort to educate on the contamination of recyclable
materials. Are we seeing an improvement in that?
Yes, we are. And we're currently working with our processor right now
to find out what that new rate is. When I arrived,
I believe our contamination rate was around 39%.
We're going to be doing another evaluation within
the next couple of weeks, in the next week or two, and we expect that
rate to be down. Terrific. We're already seeing indications fantastic.
And if I could go back in queue, please make sure council Member Amy Pick.
Thank you, Mayor Pertem. And thank you, Director. First, I want to thank you for
the work that you're doing, especially in District Day. We've seen a huge improvement
in collections since you've been on board. And when
we were meeting about using our service funds to
supplement the work, your question was
you weren't just, of course we'll take your money. You were really
questioning, well, why are we not picking it up on time? And I really appreciated
how you were thinking about that. So my question is about
the business recycling program and the commercial collections.
Have those two programs been evaluated recently to see if it's
beneficial to continue that financially
or if that's something we should suspend or increase or has
that been evaluated? Yes, and we're currently
working with some partners here. When I say partners,
I mean these are big partners, ExxonMobil and whatnot. So we have
the small scale recycling,
commercial recycling program for the small producers and small businesses.
And that seems to be working relatively well right now. We know that there
are some opportunities for improvement, and we're working on addressing that
right now. But perhaps I think the biggest takeaway is that
a lot of the partners that want to work with us right now,
they see the value in that program. They appreciate the fact
that we've gotten started and they're ready to help us take it to the next
level. So abandoning it would not be the
right choice at this time. And as far as the commercial collections for
trash pickup, is that something that has been evaluated, too, where commercial
businesses can basically contract with the city for a pickup? That's something
that I'm evaluating right now. I still need to spend some time with our revenue
and finance team, but I do see some serious potentials
in there. Okay, thank you. We can't keep giving away the business.
Council Member Sally Alcorn.
Thank you, Chair, and thank you, director, for your presentation.
You're operating according to the solid waste, long range solid waste
plan at a $20 to $40 million deficit.
Correct. Just walking in the door. $20 to $40 million
down, we're picking up 391,000
homes. Correct. We've got another 50,000 on
sponsorship that are paying their own private trash.
Correct. I really appreciated your slide that
had the different cities on there. I would add
that those cities that you
have on those slides, especially Dallas, San Antonio and Austin, all have a
fee. The fee in
Dallas is $34.30.
Weekly garbage and recycling, monthly brush and bulky bulk
waste. Austin has pay as you throw ranges from
twenty two dollars and sixty five cents to forty nine dollars and fifty
cents a month. San Antonio,
$14 through they also have pays. You throw through
$26. It's employees
and it's equipment. And I don't see how you get there
with $96 million a year from the general fund.
So I'd like you to give me
your experience in Tampa and any other experience you have with
how a fee was originated and
how you think that might play out here. Absolutely,
sure. In Tampa, as well as other enterprise
fund departments in the solid waste industry,
fee was a little bit higher in Tamps, around $36 per household.
But that fee was also covering the cost
of the service. So employees
and equipment first supplies the other associated
expenses that come along with managing a solid waste program.
People often forget about the true cost of disposal.
Those are real dollars. So when we show up at a
disposal facility at a landfill and we have to drive across someone's
scales, there's no sort of internal fund transfer that
satisfies that transaction. There's a check that they're looking for and that disposal
cost usually cost about a third of the service.
And if I was going to rank it, I would probably rank it somewhere between
number one and three. When it comes down to the
assets, it's going to be right there. Between the cost of employees and the cost
of equipment are the three greatest
costs of that service. So again, that's what your rate is designed
to cover. In Tampa, we also had a different
disposal system, so we had a bond to cover. So our rate was
designed to cover the cost of satisfying the bond each
year. However, once we reached the areas
and the bonds matured and we paid that bond off, we enjoyed a $14
million swing. Really, it's about a $28 million
swing. All of that money did not stay in the department.
We can't show a profit. We cover our reserves,
rainy day funds and whatnot. The rest of that has to go back to the
general fund in order to support other areas of the city.
So whenever you hear me talk about a rate or bringing on a
rate, it's number one to take care of what we need to take care
of in house so that we can deliver the on time service and have the
equipment that we need so that our men and women can show up
and deliver that and not have to stay out until eight or 09:00
at night or come in on a Sunday. But it's to cover that
first and then support the other areas of the city that need it second.
And when you talk about the city of Houston, we got a lot of work
to do, right. So if we were to embark upon that road,
it's going to be a couple of years before we start seeing the benefits of
that return. But the goal would be, again, as I mentioned earlier, to reduce
our dependency on the general fund and allow those funds to
be used for other areas throughout the city.
I told Council Member Pat I was offended when she sat across
from me and said that she wanted to run her solid waste
programs like, well, what are we?
And I know Houston has gotten away with it, but I think with the
times and conditions and the way things are today,
we've got to find some way to offset that, and I think our residents and
customers deserve better. Council Member
Carolyn Evan Shabbaz. Thank you, Mayor Protem. And thank you,
director. I don't know if you ever settled. I know we talked about
living in district d, but at any rate,
I'm just curious. We talked before about hot teams and
how only some districts have to employ
people for hot teams. In my particular district,
we employ four people and pay for two trucks.
And I think we talked about how that cost could possibly be absorbed
because it does take out of our districts,
whereas there are others that don't have to pay those costs.
So I didn't see anything in the budget regarding
that, and so I'm encouraged that there's still an opportunity.
So maybe you can address that in terms of making that
a little bit more equitable. Thank you. And to make sure I understand
your question, are you talking about being able to cover the cost of
what the hot teams are providing or expenses associated with
all districts? I don't think all the districts
have them. There are those that do, but there are all districts. Do you
have one? A hot team? No. Okay.
No. We're talking about solid waste right now.
So I'm not trying to compare what each person pays,
but my question is we have to hire four. I have in my case,
we are four men or women,
and we pay for two trucks for trash
pickup. And I'm just wondering because you and
I had the conversation not trying to say that others don't pay for other
things, that I may pay for something that you may not, but somewhat
it just doesn't somewhat seem equitable for
some districts to have to pay for hot teams and employ
additional people to pick up that which all Houstonians
expect. Right. And so if you could address that,
I'd appreciate it. Absolutely. And I think what we may be seeing
is it may speak to trying
to find the right way to say this, the difference in neighborhoods
throughout the city of Houston, as large as it is.
You have some neighborhoods where we see development
occurring, and as that development is occurring, we notice the amount
of illegal dumping and the needs for hot teams will
kind of draw down. In other districts. They may have
a few more commercial areas than residential areas, so their
approach may be a little bit different. It may be a quarterly approach or
something of that nature. But what we're seeing and what I'm observing is
that each district has its own unique features,
and one district may require a hot team. And we appreciate
the hot teams because they kind of fill in the
gap right now where we want to, but we just can't because we're trying
to address the more pressing issues. And I think that's why you
may see that from as I travel throughout and I look at some of the
neighborhoods and I see where there is a greater need for
some of those areas. And I think the wonderful thing that I've learned about City
of Houston, I was kind of kicking myself because I wish I would have met
with them on the first day that I was here is the Mayor's Office of
Innovation and Sustainability. They've got some wonderful
ideas. And we were chatting the other day about now
that we know where a majority of our debris is being generated at
what kind of programs, how can we augment our programs so that we can
concentrate our equipment in those areas and not as
heavy on the areas where there is not as much generation
of the illegal dumping and whatnot? And I think that's why a lot of
times you'll see that difference. Right. I do understand that it's a difference,
but we had talked about it, and I didn't know if you were able to
do that, which we talked about, but apparently not at this
juncture, not at this time. But we're still working on it. We haven't forgot
about that request. Thank you. And in fact, I'm going to address
something in your district pretty soon.
Vice chair, Ed Pollard.
Chatty Cathy over there. Thank you, Chair, and thank you,
Director, for your presentation. A couple
of things. One,
if we were to have a fee, what would be
some of the priority areas of your department
that would see an impact from that fee from
the jump? Would it be additional drivers? Would it be pay for
additional equipment? Like, where would that money go towards? Right.
So when you say from the jump for us, from the jump means
at least a year out with the time
that's required to secure equipment and the
shortages and the backlogs and what it takes to
secure that equipment, you're talking about a good year,
a year and a half out. So what you would see
right off the bat is on time service. So you put your recycling
container out on Monday, and that's your schedule collection day. It's collected by
Monday at 05:00. Okay, thank you. And also, I just want to give
you a shout out for being real open minded about the District J Private
Trash Day and working with our office to collaborate on ways
in which to make that program efficient. It's something that we're
continuing and that the constituents seem to find beneficial.
So thank you again. Look forward to continuing working with you.
Thank you, Director. Wilfred, I must say, you've done
a bang up job in your initial time here. I used to always tell everybody,
I love me some Harry Hayes. I'll always love me some Harry Hayes.
But you've done a great job coming in and picking up what Harry Hayes
started developing. I hate to see Mr. Anthony Bowie
retiring. And I see Ms. Carolyn out there.
They did a great job for us many, many times,
and especially in 2017, when I had the
blessing and the honor of working with, I think, one of
your counterparts. He actually did a stint in Temp in Tampa.
Mr. Mccreck, Kerry, and David ran solid waste
in San Antonio at the time. And Jessica and I spent literally 40
days in a row with them, never missing a day. And he and I
would talk about various things. And one of the things that struck me is he
was telling me that you all had a waste energy
plant in Tampa and you would sell the waste to the
energy electric company and they would move the
waste into electricity. Is there any option for
us here in the city to do something similar to what you did in Tampa?
I would love it. It is an expensive undertaker,
I tell you, but it is definitely
a way to save space, and it eliminates
the need for the landfills. That's the biggest value right there.
So, idea wise, how much does it cost?
Today, you're probably looking at about a billion dollars. Yeah.
The last one that I know of that was permitted in South Florida was about
880,000,000. And that was about three or four years ago.
Okay. And another quick question. Years ago,
we made a lot of money on commodities.
The commodity market was a lot different. How is it today? I know that
I'm literally thinking maybe six, seven years ago, we were making a good deal
of money on commodities and then went south on us, and then we started paying
waste management to take our commodities. Is there
any coming back in that market I haven't really looked at? Yeah, it's kind of
leveled out, but we're still not seeing what you all enjoyed
during that time ago. In fact, from Florida, I used to
look at that and I used to catch heat because people would say,
how come you're not doing what Texas is doing? But again, it's a
regional market. It's very volatile.
I definitely wouldn't bet my life savings on
it. But right now, we're kind of breaking even in
that recycling market as far as the commodities are concerned. Thank you,
Director Bowie. We'll miss you. You've done a
great job for us, for you. And so have you, director Wright. Even though you're
not going anywhere, we're not letting you. Council member Robert Gallegos.
Thank you, Mayor Pro TEM. Thank you, Director, for the presentation.
It was enjoyed visiting with you last week
in regards to getting some updates, I know
that leaving my office right now.
Constituent services pointed out to me that we have a constituent that has
been waiting for a trash can, because I believe their trash can was
stolen, and they've been waiting for a. Trash can since April.
I know that we have some trash cans that
are sitting on Capitol Street that they're still been waiting for
that trash to be picked up. And I say all this
because I want you to elaborate what's happening
in regards to trucks breaking down, the lack of hiring
employees. That way the general public can hear exactly
what the issues are because all
they see is that they want their can and the can is not being delivered.
Right. All they're seeing is that they want their trash can picked up and their
trash hasn't been delivered until they call our office and we try to
explain to them what the situation is. If we're leaning
towards a fee, we need to let the public
know why. So if you can elaborate what the
issues are, please. Yeah, and there's several compounding
issues and I think we also want to be clear to say that
the fee gets us going in the right direction. It's not the magic elixir.
So what people may be experiencing when they
run into those delays is, again, we're dealing
with 420 some odd employees department wide.
That's not enough. 645 sq mi.
645 sq mi. Exactly. So what
you see the team doing is concentrating on the big
fires and trying to keep those from growing even larger.
So if somebody's waiting on a can, it could very well be because
another team member was reassigned to take care of a route and
that may have been more pressing that day. We have
some systems that we also have to kind of update and how
we as it pertains to logistics and maybe
service order management to kind of make that a little bit more electronic
than manual. So that's part of the growth and development opportunities that
we have in the department that we haven't been able to take advantage of.
And again, you mentioned earlier about the vehicles. Some of the
vehicles in our fleet are as old as
minimum ten years old. And the average life of a garbage truck
should be around five to seven years. You should be replacing them.
So we've got to get that vehicle replacement program up
to where it should be so that once we know that five to seven
year mark is there, we're looking at trying to replace that. Because believe
it or not, you're spending more money on maintaining that vehicle
than the vehicle is now worth. So when those vehicles
break down, if the manufacturers and you've got your
three models or four models in now, you've got to wait on a part to
be fabricated in order to get that vehicle fixed,
which means it has to sit and wait for a couple of weeks longer.
And all of that when you don't have, again, two greatest assets the absence
of employees, the absence of equipment. You're going to experience
those delays in services. So the
model that the team has generated that seems to be effective right now.
They're always going to concentrate on garbage first.
We don't want that to sit out for days and whatnot
and draw the flies and vectors that come along with that. And then we'll
make up the recycling a little bit later during the week. So just
a snapshot of the delay. And what I've stated to your predecessor,
Director Hayes, when he brought this to my attention years ago, that we were
needing a garbage fee because all these other major cities in the state of Texas
have a monthly garbage fee. What I
stated as when I was president of my civic club and president of the super
neighborhood. And I've asked and mentioned this to civic
clubs when I go out and they start talking about missed pickups and
what have you regarding trash is that if there is a garbage fee,
in my opinion, I'm hoping it's not just to pick
up your trash can and your recycling
bid. It's also going to be to pick up those tires that
are being dumped on the vacant lot. It's also to be pick up that illegal
dumping, that's being dumped in the neighborhood, that's bringing down our neighborhood,
that's causing crime because of all this illegal dumping.
So it's a catch 22 and we pay a
monthly garbage fee. Constituents are going to expect more than just
picking up the trash can and your recycling bin. And that's
what I'm hoping will happen is that we'll be able to pick up those tires
while I'm able to pick up the illegal dumping and clean up our neighborhoods at
the same time. And I think the majority of the public will
go with it. Exactly. Just to add
on to that, again, there are some opportunities to create some more
programs that concentrate on solid waste. And I know we have code enforcement
officers and we work with our neighborhood department with that.
But in order to address the issues that we have
now, I really feel that there would be some benefits for the solid waste department
to have its own code enforcement team, maybe two or three
for each sector. And as we see these illegal
dumping issues pop up, it gives us an opportunity to concentrate
the time that's needed on mitigating the issues. And I know you brought that
up to me when we met. And I totally agree that there needs to
be code enforcement inspectors inside of waste so that those
that end up putting their illegal dumping out a day
or two after it was already picked up in the neighborhood, they can be told
you're not supposed to do this. Give them a warning and hopefully they
will stop doing that in that way of cleaning up our neighborhoods.
Council Member David Robinson. Thank you, chair Director,
thanks very much for all the reasons colleagues have said. I wanted
to pick up not only on points made
about the requisite collaboration that
you have to do with other departments, whether that's the dawn in
the case of potential generation of
electricity that the Chair asked you about, we know
that's real. We witnessed it ourselves. Mayor Pro
TEM on our recent trip to Denmark, which is
where we were escorted with the delegation, was really about
the Public Works Department. And that's where the
importance of your collaboration, Director, with those
who have maybe more infrastructure dollars in their
departments already. Or ways in which we can bridge
the gap between our solid waste management concerns
and how we might actually embrace
how your part of our annual budget becomes
part of our generation of electricity and our utility
structure and part of what we're doing with the overall maintenance and
management of our resources.
And I know that's not news to you with your experience in Tampa.
It's something I mean, you did throw out the billion
dollar figure for a plant.
And I'd like to observe that that is a really fungible
number that's not set at one point.
Repeating billion, that's scalable in a lot of different directions.
How you do it, what you do with the money, is entirely
subject to how we might devise or design a program.
And so in your six months here, I know you've already brought
a lot of innovation to the department. And I'm so pleased
to see it and witness the work you're doing. I want
to encourage you to continue to work with the Office of Innovation
in the Mayor's department as well as the Sustainable Office.
And that's really my comment. If you have anything to add to that,
I'd love to hear it. Thank you. Council Member Robinson I
don't want that billion dollars to scare you, right? It's a big number.
But you got to look at the value of that beyond the
dollars and cents. So that's land
that you're not taking up that could probably be used for
housing or some sort of future development or just
preservation or whatever the case may be. And then the amount
of revenue that you generate from the sale of energy, which you have
to be careful of nowadays because you have other forms
of energy that are now competitive on the market, CNG and
whatnot you have to watch that, but it does
go towards offsetting that expense. And just
to give you a quick story of my level of ignorance, when I was appointed
to be Director in Tampa, the first thing I wanted to do was sell the
waste energy plant because it cost us 10 million
to run and we only got 5 million in return.
I'm like, this doesn't make sense. But then I thought about it.
Where are we going to go? Our trucks are going to have to drive 60
miles now just to go to one landfill. So the value of
having that waste energy plant there was
more than just the dollars and cents. Appreciate that very much.
Council Member Abby Cayman Director
normally I ask a question, the question everyone's heard
it already about the needs of the department looking forward, but I think you've covered
a lot of those in terms of looking ahead at the future and
what we need. Is there anything you want to add to that
that has not been discussed? I'm glad you asked.
No, but we did. We covered a lot of it.
As far as any sort of unmet needs as it
relates to that. You heard me talk about vehicle
coordination. That really involves having someone in our department that
just focuses on nothing but vehicles. And they
maintain this outstanding relationship with fleet maintenance.
They hold us accountable, make sure that we're taking care of the equipment
and then they also work with fleet maintenance to make sure vehicles are available.
You heard me speak often about code enforcement officers as well,
a necessary part, additional drivers.
Right now, probably one of the most startling things that I've seen is I go
out on route run into, believe it's
Daniel Williams at the Southeast Service Center. And he's
picking up and I asked him how many homes does he have on his route
and he tells me 3000. I said he's exaggerating. I get back
to the service center to know he's telling the truth. And that's an
example of the department continuously trying
its quest to want to serve our public and
provide that service and giving us everything we got.
But I can tell you 3000 homes for one driver is unrealistic.
The truck will be throwing in the towel at that point in time. They said
they can't do it. We end up overworking the driver in the truck and we
end up in a bad situation.
Again, I definitely want to continue to focus on the illegal dumping this here.
I want to see if we can start dropping some more cameras throughout the city
in some of those areas that have a lot of that unnecessary activity,
see if we can curb some of that behavior. Public Works has been
great to work with as well. We're going to find some of the roads
that are less traveled, like what we had on the news the other day,
and see if we can just block some of the ingress and egress off to
curb that behavior. Well, again, I appreciate it and like
you said, one team or
one person having to deal with 3000 homes,
we shouldn't be asking any city employee to deal with
that. So, thanks. My gratitude again. And also I know you've
really put your head to the ground trying to figure out
some new and unique ways of recruiting and job training.
So I just appreciate the leadership
you and your team are providing. Thank you. Council Member
Sally Alcorn. Thank you, Chair. What are our
annual tipping fees? I believe we hover around
25 $26 per ton.
And on the recycling revenue?
The recycling fund performance measures, it has 12% curbside
recycling. What exactly does that mean? What is that figure?
It's on the performance measures in the budget book. It says curbside
recycling rate, single stream, 12% target.
I'm not familiar. I have to look that up. You're saying it's in the budget
book?
Roman numeral ten, 164. Okay.
There's some targets. It's the same target as last year. I just don't know what
that means. What's that? 12%. Okay, thank you.
And you mentioned 15% critical vacancies in
numbers. I'm curious on how many drivers you're
down. About 55 right now. 55?
55 drivers. Okay.
What other critical positions are vacant?
Those are going to be the critical. Those are critical. Okay, so when you talk
critical vacancies, you're talking about drivers. Yeah, we're talking about drivers.
And you're in the works of bringing those
entry level salaries up? Absolutely. Mayor Turner
and I have been working together and he's
authorized a 6% increase. And now when we
go out, we're also increasing the number of job fairs
that we're attending working with our HR department, jane Cheeks and her team.
Okay, great. And thank you
for your help on composting. I noticed it on your accomplishments, the composting drop off.
And thank you for working with the Office of Innovation and my team on what
might come next. I agree with Council Member Gallegos. I think that the fee
is going to have to come with some extras. And I think if we do
go to curbside recycling like other cities, it would be a
voluntary program and an additional fee on the people who want to participate.
And you'd be surprised how many want to participate. Denver has started
this and there's thousands and thousands. But I
can't put anything more on the solid waste department.
We're trying to get less trash so we can save more of
that $25 per ton in shipping fees. Absolutely. Thank you.
Council member Tasha Jackson. Thank you. And thank you,
director, and your team. I just wanted to commend you guys on a great job
that you're doing. Just working with you,
our hot team. Of course I have the hot team. And you had a conversation
about that. I was hoping we can pull them out, but we
can't. So we can use our dollars somewhere else. But you
can see the difference. You can see the neighborhood is a little
bit cleaned, a little bit better, but we
need more work and I know we need more money. And so I just want
you to know I support the fee if you guys
approach that. Approach that because I know we need dollars to move the follow waste
department together forward. But I just want to say congratulations and thank you for
everything that you're doing. Thank you. If I can just add to that,
and I've heard Mayor Turner mention it as well,
another part of success, even though it doesn't involve this, is the funding,
ARPA funding and some of the grant funding that we're able to take advantage of.
I would really like to position the department so that when that funding
goes away, we can continue to maintain some of these programs that
we're able to embark upon right now. And I did ask my question,
the anti litter campaign. So would that continue? Because that's been a big
help. Yes, we are actually in the process of evaluating bids on
that right now. Okay. So that will continue, and you should not experience
a gap in that. That's been the help. So thank you so much for keeping
that council member, Robert Gallegos. Thank you
for Tim. And again, thank you, Director, for everything. You're doing an outstanding
job. I know you're new here and you're getting all these headaches,
but you're doing a great job. So thank you. I just
also want to mention that if we do go with the possibly in
the near future, in the future, a fee that
also, hopefully we follow. I understand Director Hayes had mentioned the
San Antonio model where they have a large trash can. They have
a small trash can, and it depends on the homeowner.
If they have quite a bit of trash, then they'll be paying for a large
trash can, whatever that monthly fee is.
If they have a small trash can, then they'll be paying a little less than
what that normal fee is. So hopefully that's another
model that we can follow also, and that
also encourages people to put more recycling stuff into
your recycling bin, so that way you'll have a smaller trash can and pay
less on your fee. So I'm hoping that's something that
we can look at as well. I'm with you
100%. I can't even speak. You're talking just as much trash as
I am right now. So there are
no other council members in queue. I'll ask my last question a
couple of years ago. This is probably six years ago.
As you well know, many areas of the city have
private trash collection, and we pay them $6 a month
per household for them
to get their private collection. We looked at eliminating
that, and we discovered that eliminating that would cost
us a ton of money more, mainly because we don't have the workforce
and we don't have the trucks. So we kept that intact. So when
you talk about garbage fee, I know it would have to
be across the board, so everyone in the city of Houston would have
to be a part of it. So let's say if you have 500,000
households and it was $72 a
year, $6 a month times twelve months,
that would equate to probably around $34 million that we could
use on something like that. But my question to you, I'm not sure what you
had in Tampa or your other experience.
How difficult is it to get folks that are on private collection
where we really in order for us to pick it up,
it would cost us probably three or four times the $6 a month.
Right. How do we put the genie back in the bottle? In that
case, I think we offer a rate that is just as
competitive as the private company that is providing that current
level of service. I think although we pay $6
a month, I believe that those residents are actually paying a little bit more to
the company. We just
have to make sure that we cover our cost of service. And normally with municipalities,
that rate is a little bit lower than our private counterparts.
They are there to turn a profit. We're there for reliability.
So if we cover our cost of service, we should be just
as competitive. However,
we're to the position right now, like you mentioned earlier, we can't take on any
additional service right now. So the key to doing that is
to crawl before we walk. Yeah.
Great. Thank you. And before I leave, another great employee,
fairly new Veronica, doing a great job for us. So thank you.
I'll pass that along. Council Member Sally Alcorn. Thank you, chair.
And just to jump in, I just want to be clear. If you have private
trash right now, you're already paying a fee for your private trash.
You would not be paying the city's trash fee.
It would be like clear, like water authority, people not paying
the drainage. Calm down. I didn't say that. I know exactly what we
pay. We get $6 a month,
$72 a year. And we pay waste management or a
trash collection in addition to it. So my
question is if we talk about a garbage fee and it goes citywide,
there is no way on God's green earth these guys will be able to pick
it up right away. No way. Yeah. So you'd keep your private trust. Yeah.
And all you hear me talk about building it up. Right. Building those
reserves. The first priority should be reducing
our dependency on the general fund. That means we're able to stand on
our own. Once we do that, we don't take on
any additional service until we can cover the costs. That means that we
have the employees and equipment to provide that service. Exactly. So you have to have
a build up, take you a year to buy equipment and employees. And from
what we're experiencing right now, we can't get drivers. Right. So how are you going
to get drivers to do citywide? Mayor Turner. And I got a
plan. We're going to turn that around. You got a plan? I like that.
Well, thank you. Appreciate it. Thanks for your time. Thank you. We have a
1234 public speakers. We'll start it out
with Mr. Jason Oliver.
Star six to unmute.
First, I'm concerned about driver safety.
I know that solid waste has been doing a lot with
very little and it seems like even less this year in
the budget we're looking at. Council member Cayman talked about early days and
late nights with people working six days a week. I recall reading an article about
a driver fainting and we're approaching the summer, how are we taking
care of driver safety and are we making improvements there?
And then a second question to follow up on something Council Member Pollard said,
because I want to make sure I know who to direct my comments to.
Directors report. He said Directors report to the mayor and they were directed to leave.
It sounds like you're telling us that it's not city council, but the mayor who
directed city staff not to respond to our questions. So I just want to make
sure should we be directing our concerns about this policy to council
or to the mayor?
You can direct your questions to council if you
have a direct question for council, if you have a question
that is specific to a director, you can submit
those to your council office and we would send those to the director to
get a response for you. Right,
but the policy change that was made around
budget workshops that we hadn't had in previous years, I'm trying to
figure out how we get that back. Yes,
council Member Cayman jason, just to be clear, I said
this before, I'm not chair of BFA, so I can't
speak for that. But what I do know as a chair of a committee is
there is always, including at public safety been
a standing procedural rule
where questions are taken from the public,
submitted to the departments and then responded to.
My understanding is also in terms of time, things like
that. We've already been here and I was going to thank
Saba and others for sitting here all day. I understand
the commitment. All I'm explaining is this wasn't
a rule change. The chair even
indicated that we messed up the
first go round. It has always been in our
committees that questions are submitted from
the public, they're submitted to the departments for a response. For example,
my staff takes all questions from public safety comments,
submits them to department and then emails them back. So I just wanted again,
I'm not telling you which way to feel about it, but I wanted
to speak up for the chair in terms of other
committees, that has been the standard process as
well.
Right, but not for the budget workshops. We've been here in
previous years. So I just want to be clear about like, that's not general
practice and it hasn't been standard practice in previous years.
The recordings show it.
I've been sitting here for nine years doing this,
so I think I know a little bit about it.
But anyway, I appreciate your comments. Jason,
good to have you here this week. Jill Grochell,
star six to unmute. Jill saba
Blanding. If Jill's in, we'll come back to you.
I had a couple of questions, but I believe what Jason
speaking to is the fact that last year we were able to
direct our questions to the department heads during the budget
workshops. I don't know if that
was a change because it was virtual, but we definitely had the opportunity last
year, so I can't speak to prior years.
Thank you. We did a lot of different things during COVID when
everyone was virtual. So maybe we just need to
go back to everything being virtual. I'm not a big fan of that, but you're
right, we did a lot of different things last year in
a virtual environment because of that. Yeah,
it was really nice and I appreciated it as a constituent, I don't disagree.
In past workshops, we've been told that we start every day behind
based on low budget for staffing. And so in regards to trash, where are
we in terms of the routes we have versus the routes we need based on
population growth? I believe there's a little bit of an addressing
routes, but just some more details there. And then
actually, several council members address this.
Do you mind if I ask a quick question? Go ahead. Okay, so we've been
told in the past that solid waste needs somewhere around 40 million for additional personnel
and equipment to get up to basic adequate level of service. Okay, so just
updates on that need for the immediate future. Council Member Alcorn and
Pollard, you both brought up the discussion of fees for solid waste.
I'm just curious how this could be applied equitably so that every
Houstonian has access to trash collection and recycling
because illegal dumping is already an issue. And so just everyone
having access to trash and then,
yeah, that's it. Council Member
Pollard so I think we have to really strategically
look at how we put forth the fee. What does that fee get you?
How is it equal across the board, especially when it comes to
those who may have resources and those who may not. So that's a discussion
that we need to have before I think we do anything with the
fee. I think we really need to educate the voters and
the constituents on what's done in other cities.
What can be expected here in this city? What are the pros?
Maybe some of the cons and some of the realistic expectations,
but it is a conversation that we need to have and we
really need to be able to hear your voice on that when we
bring forth what the possibilities are.
But we are the only city, major city in the state of Texas
and maybe even in the US. That does not have that fee.
And so we have to find ways in which, if we do pay a fee,
all communities get a benefit and see
a benefit beyond just normal trash, but also
looking into the uniqueness of each area, whether it's illegal dumping
or whatever, to address those needs as well.
So I'll give you my personal deal. I get my
trash picked up by a contractor. I'm one of the folks
that we get $6 a month from the city not
to pick up our trash. That goes to our homeowners association,
who in turn pays for the private trash collection.
We have what's called back door driveway
trash collection. So they go down the street and they roll up to your
driveway and empty your can and dump it into a bigger can. Then the truck
comes behind it, and we get that two days a week. Ours comes Tuesday,
Friday. We have recycles pick up every Thursday.
So we are very happy with our
trash collection. So if we do go to our garbage fee and we
have to change it, we better do equal
or better, or I will get more complaints,
more complaints under the sun than I care to deal with.
But one of the things that we had an issue
with five, six years ago I forgot when
it was, was when we started looking at the elimination of private
trash collection. We realized we didn't have the people and we didn't have the
equipment to do it. So I'm not sure what Sally
Alcorn has to say over there, but we love
our private trash collection, and we pay for it, and we're glad
to pay for it. So if I have to
sit here and vote for a garbage fee, and I argued with Harry Hayes for
years about it, it's going to be tough for me to do that,
because what we have works extremely
well. All of the cities that
I mentioned earlier on all of the cities that have the fee,
you can opt out of the fee and keep your private trash.
Nobody's going to make anybody who has private trash get
city trash. Can I quote you on that, Mayor? Mayor Al
Corn because there's only one person that can state that, and he's up one floor.
Well, a fee that I would support would not
require people to give up their private trash.
Let's quote let's run that tape back, broderick. Mr.
Butler. Stop it. You got any additional yeah.
And I appreciate Council Member Pollard address this I'm not worried about the constituents that
can't afford the fee. I'm worried about those where, like, every dollar
is in them being able to access
trash and recycling, because we don't want to see that go there.
Okay, thank you. Thank you. I will not be here tomorrow, so thanks
for coming for every meeting. Thank you.
Stick around. I'll talk to you a little bit. Broad Butler,
Northeast Houston, Myrtle Beach,
South Carolina does an excellent job of
eliminating illegal dumping. I wish you would take a look at their
plan. It went all the way to the state level. They have an agreement between
the city and the state to deal
with illegal dumping. But my comments are I
want to apologize for losing my composure earlier. I respect the decision.
I didn't expect you to reverse it. But to
sit here and be told. That well compensated, educated and seasoned
directors are being shielded from. Speaking to the public is frustrating.
But I apologize to the entire council for letting my
passions get the better of me. I'd like to acknowledge
the solid waste department on our side of town in Northeast
Houston. Alice Coffey, Richard Wynn, and Desmond Allen
are names that all Northeast residents know. They have
worked harder. When they have failed, they have stepped up.
And everything that the director told you
about, we already know as citizens because we have a communication
and a dialogue with their staff. So outside
of that, I wish every city department would resemble the
solid waste staff department. And again, Myrtle Beach,
South Carolina. So do you know anything about what they do? Because we
talk about yeah, I read the whole plan one
night when I was running for city council. Would you run
against I have no idea. But they were victorious,
and we're going to go with it because in my eyes today, they stood
10ft tall. And I'll say that again, so I'm very proud of them. Myrtle Beach,
South Carolina. All I did one night, I said, everybody's got a
thought on this. And then I just went to the Google machine and I said,
give me the best solution for illegal dumping. It said, Myrtle Beach,
South Carolina. Their economy depends on tourism.
For people to come to this wonderful clear beach in South
Carolina. But they had an economic downturn and
all this trash showed up. Nobody wanted tourists to
come and see a filthy city. They were going to lose millions of
dollars. They came up with a garbage fee. It was $3.
Ended up being $11. The fee was specific
to hire only a team along
with their solid waste department. But that team only
went out and removed illegal dumping. I thought it didn't make
a lot of sense, but as I talked to residents here, they didn't care how
it worked. They just want the trash gone. So Myrtle
Beach created a standalone hot
team. That's all they did. They went throughout
the entire city and removed trash, and it worked very
well. Then the city went to the legislature
and asked them to increase the fines for people
who did illegal dumping. So they had to buy in from the
state, the county, and the state legislature. Sorry,
the city, the county, and the state legislature. So that if you
did dump in Myrtle Beach, South Carolina, you were going to do
jail time and you were going to lose a whole lot of money.
And so now Myrtle Beach is again,
they have one of the best responses to the issue, which is
basically, you come here, you dump, you will
either go to jail or you will be fined
into the Stone Age. And it has worked well for
them. I'm looking it up right now, and it's interesting.
A lot of our issues emanates from the state of texas. And the reason why
I say that is we have a problem not with
illegal dumping, but with sand mining operations. And we discovered that
it was less expensive for them to keep illegally sending
sand into our tributaries than it is to remediate it.
So they kept doing it and they kept paying the fines and they paid them
gladly. But you won't solve that problem until you raise the
fines high enough to where it actually hurts them. And it sounds like reading
on Myrtle Beach that's exactly what they did through the state.
And they got the buy in so that they weren't a standalone island
trying to solve a problem that other cities were eventually
going to have in South Carolina. Right. Well, I'll finish reading it, but your other
comment no need to apologize. I appreciate your
vigor and vitality. I think I'm somewhat
like that. Well, but reason people should be able
to have a discourse because at the end of the day, some of these
directors, they don't deal with apparati, they deal with people's lives.
So it kind of matters to us that we're the lives they might be dealing
with one day. Thank you. We appreciate
the efforts of the council and thank you for your time. You got
it. Thank you. Before we adjourn, please note budget workshops
will continue this week through Thursday, May 19. Our next budget presentation will
be special called BFA committee meeting tomorrow,
Thursday the 19th at 09:00 A.m..
I will be out. I will be in Austin, Texas as my son Michael is
graduating tomorrow at 11:00 a.m.
Hookham. Hookham. So Julie
and I will be there and my daughter will be there for the next couple
of days. Participate in the festivities of the University city
of Texas.
Hookum. We got it. Meet and adjourn.
Have a blessed day. Have a great evening. Come to Clear Lake and come see
us. Sally Alcorn.